Нехай МВФ і вважає Україну найбіднішою державою Європи -
відповідно до осіннього прогнозу розвитку світової економіки.
Нехай наводить розрахунки про найменший показник ВВП на душу населення
серед європейських країн - менше трьох тисяч доларів та 134 місце у світовому рейтингу:
між Бутаном та Філіппінами з одного боку, та Гондурасом і Лаосом з іншого.
Проте всі українців знають - не в такій вже й злиденній країні вони живуть.
Особливо порівняно з екваторіальною Африкою або сусідкою-Молдовою,
яка вперше обійшла Україну в рейтингу МВФ.
Адже за багатством природних ресурсів та розвиненістю промисловості
Україна суттєво випереджає ту ж Молдову, яка живе за рахунок експорту вина,
фруктів та грошових переказів заробітчан.
Проте тепер, завдяки кільком рокам реформ, навіть аграрна Молдова обігнала Україну:
і за рівнем ВВП на душу населення,
і навіть за середньою офіційною зарплатою, яка на 50 доларів вища, ніж в Україні.
Результати щорічного звіту Credit Suisse про світовий добробут - підтверджують дані МВФ.
Україна - в самому кінці рейтингу.
На першому місці - Швейцарія, в якої на кожного дорослого мешканця
припадає по 530 тисяч доларів США.
В Німеччині, наприклад, 280 тисяч на кожного дорослого,
в Росії - майже 20 тисяч, в тій же Молдові - 3 тисячі на людину.
В України ж - лише півтори тисячі доларів.
За цим рейтингом Україна удвічі програє Молодові, в 13 разів - Росії та у 180 разів Німеччині.
Здавалося б, рівень життя в Україні має бути значно вищий.
Тим паче, що з-під уламків СРСР Україна вийшла другою
за величиною економікою Радянського Союзу.
Через майже тридцять років 60% українців, за даними ООН,
живуть за межею бідності, а за версією Світового банку - таких 25%.
І це на тлі величезного розриву між багатими та бідними,
коли віп-автомобілі продаються краще, ніж автівки середнього класу,
а світові бренди класу люкс представлені в Україні краще, ніж компанії масового ринку.
Чому ж так?
Головна причина - відсутність реформ, які свого часу вивели країни Балтії, Польщу та Чехію
на новий якісний рівень, і проведення яких українці досі очікують.
Політики не йдуть на докорінні реформи як через вплив олігархів,
так і через небажання псувати собі рейтинги.
Українським підприємцям у свою чергу простіше і надійніше продавати за кордон сировину,
ніж будувати новий завод, щоб виробляти продукцію з високою доданою вартістю
та створювати нові робочі місця.
Окрім того, ринок землі досі не відкритий, а масштабної приватизації не відбулося.
Як наслідок західні інвестори не приходять, люди не мають роботи, а держава - податків.
Натомість олігархи та агрохолдинги зберігають свої монополії, а політики - йдуть на перевибори.
І хоча після кризи 2014-го українська економіка зростає 10-й квартал поспіль,
але повільніше, ніж в середньому у світі. А значить - відставання України збільшується.
І нехай українські експерти пояснюють погані показники тим,
що МВФ користується неправильною методологією,
яка виходить тільки з "білих" - офіційних зарплат,
ділить ВВП країни ще й на мешканців окупованого Донбасу і Криму,
а також на мільйони трудових мігрантів, які виїхали з України.
Проте ці фактори так чи інакше присутні в багатьох країнах.
Але останнє місце в Європі - все ж за Україною.
І значить, перепис населення, заробітчани чи навіть тіньова економіка - не головні причини.